when i got sober
i've been sober for 12 years now and uh
thank you and i feel like there was
like you know whenever when meth would
come up i feel like
around math and someone's like oh yeah
like jonathan davis like had a real math
problem and
i did yeah tomorrow actually tomorrow's
my 22nd
[ __ ] year dude [ __ ] dude
it's insane but yeah i used to do hot
rails like
what are hot rails is that where you
light up the the glass and then you
snort it yeah
but that's just pre-glass it was hot
because it was
like peanut butter nasty [ __ ] jet
fuel crank
yeah you yeah then then they started
cooking it with [ __ ] ethanol or some
[ __ ] and then that glass came around
and i got out right when glass started
kicking because you could do that and
you would be up for three days off one
line
yeah that crazy [ __ ] but ugh it makes me
sick just
thinking about that [ __ ] oh dude when i
think about drugs i get like i mean i i
just
[ __ ] love drugs man like i mean i
can't do them i love
that drug right there just when you did
it the initial
[ __ ] burn and all that [ __ ] and that
nasty [ __ ] that would leak out your body
that's what makes me sick but
i ain't gonna lie i loved it you feel
like you're [ __ ] superman yeah
[ __ ] do anything
yeah it was amazing i loved drinking i
loved partying i loved
all that [ __ ] but did that all start
before corn was blowing up or was that
something
that came out blew up oh so you were
embalming bodies doing meth
tuesday night in bakery in bakersfield
[ __ ] no
no no no i started doing meth when i was
when i moved to huntington beach
and there's a lot of meth there for
bakersfield and our uh
i got hooked up with someone that was
giving me tons of it there so
um like on the first album we have a
title called helmet in the bush
it's about math that's what happens
so i started doing method that was the
first record and then i got sober
right after we did the third record so i
stopped meth when we started touring
because i couldn't
function there's no way i could be up
for two days and tour and keep it
together and
i had to stop so the day we took off
onto our first tour with house of pain
and biohazard we got in our trailer
and i we built bunks and i just written
that bunk and i slept for five
[ __ ] days got up and played a show
and that's when i kicked it
wow rad man so you never toured while
you're doing meth
like uh no that it was impossible i
couldn't do meth
and [ __ ] tour i just it wouldn't work
so i started drinking
and then i became a raging alcoholic and
and cocaine occasionally when
i couldn't find it but yeah just they go
hand in hand
sure so when you're doing meth and or
you know even with cocaine and did you
have like cool
psychosis where you were hearing voices
and hallucinating and stuff
i was always smart enough to know when
to put it down
when i start thinking i start getting
paranoid or weird i would
just i'd go to bed but i saw a lot of
people
do that [ __ ] one of my meth dealers i
went to his house and he had holes on
the walls where he was like
there's there's cameras in the walls man
and then i start talking to people like
they're following me in helicopters and
i could see the agents in the bushes
it's like oh my god
you need to go to sleep um i never got
the weird crazy psychosis but
i met a lot of people that did and that
was when it gets scary oh yeah
i love psychosis man i
when i think back on on drugs and like
that's what i missed i miss watching the
people walk around
you know in my apartment who weren't
actually there
yeah dude